I have some news that might be shocking to a lot of people in our audience if I say the number
97% and climate change a lot of people in our audience know that that refers to the supposed
Consensus in our scientific community that human actions on our planet are causing climate change, and this is a number
That's very often cited. We have a ton of science around this number. We have a ton of studies that defend this number there's
97% consensus, and I have what might be very very surprising news for many people in our audience today, which is that?
I'm ready to come clean and admit that the 97% number is flawed. It's just it's not an accurate number
I don't want to call it fake news because that's giving them a win on the language which I don't want to do
But it's in an incorrect number, and if you're a climate science denier
And you're starting to feel aroused and titillated by what I'm saying
I want to encourage you to keep your clothes on just for a second because it's not that
97% is too high it actually is drastically low it appears that the real consensus over recent history on human
influence of our climate is
99.94% not 97% and this is based on a new meta-analysis that looked at more than
50,000 peer-reviewed climate change articles from 91 to 2015 and it's not 97% consensus, it's
99.94% and even that number might be too low because if you look at not 91 to 2015
But just like the last few years it appears to be
99.99 percent
consensus that human activities on our planet are
Influencing the climate and one of the major problems is that belief in the science is extremely politicized
And if you look at a recent Gallup survey, which asked people basically three questions. Are you worried about climate change?
Do you know that there's a scientific consensus and?
Do you believe that?
Humans are causing it Democrats overwhelmingly believe that those three things are true right 85 to 90 percent of Democrats are worried
They believe that there is a scientific consensus
And they believe that humans are in wincing the climate on the other hand only 35 to 42 percent of
Republicans are either aware of or concerned about or believe that humans are influencing the climate so this gets us to what I call
informational incongruity, okay
I've talked about this before you this
This is something that the audience seems to react very positively to because it identifies what I think is a major problem
Level one is like we know about an issue
We agree that it's an important issue
But we just disagree on our position is different right so like abortion abortion is a political issue
We could debate whether it's resolved or not based on roe v
Wade, but we have significant disagreement about what the policy should be on abortion a level
Ii disagreement would be we generally know about the issue, but do we disagree how important? It is so like before
same-sex marriage went national as a result of the Supreme Court decision
Most people were aware of the controversy over same-sex marriage
But some people just didn't really care about it as an issue
They didn't think it was anything we needed to deal with like listen
It's just not legal in some places and that's good and I don't care about that level
Three is a lot of people don't know about the issue level three informational incongruity
That's like Fox News viewers who might have no idea
That there's a major investigation into what took place between Trump and Russia we can't even debate the merits of it
We can't even debate the importance of it because some people aren't even aware that it is going on and on climate change
That's kind of the direction that things are going. You don't even have a majority of Republicans
Realizing that a scientific consensus exists so number one
I don't think anyone's gonna be influenced because the real number is ninety-nine point nine four versus ninety seven because if you already
trusted the 97% number you're not going to change your position because it's now ninety-nine point nine four and
If you weren't aware of that number or believed that it's fake anyway
You also don't care if it goes from 97 to 99 so I actually don't know how we can really get beyond this and start
figuring out what to do about the climate science issue
But the numbers are stunning and at this point completely undeniable
And I'm curious whether you've experienced these sort of Sciences your religion people there's people who will write in to me. I'll say David
you're touting science in a faith-based way the same way that people tell religion and I have to explain to people well hold on a
second
Science has built-in self correction mechanisms and in fact in science people are encouraged there are major rewards for people
Who can poke holes in what are the accepted scientific?
consensus
Consensus consensuses, I don't know what the plural is you can win a Nobel Prize if you debunk the consensus on science
Where do you see that in religion? You just don't you just don't but I think the religion
connection is actually closer to
Politics because there are people doing politics as religion
And I think it's bleeding into science because what you find is like you said there's die-hard Republicans that as part of their
Republican identity sure are saying that this science is just it's bunk. It's all a a green conspiracy
That's a political religion
it really has nothing to do with the science the thing that gives me a lot of hope is that when you look at the
Presidential elections when you talk about hardcore Republicans year after year after year, it's about 25 percent of us so most of us
Don't fall into that category seventy-five percent of us either look at this consensus and go like yeah
It's real or the other people in the middle that either don't know don't care a lot of people
It's not really about climate science so one of the things that I do on my show is because that's controversial
I talk more about the pollution because the solution is the same job burning fossil fuels
Yep, so there's ways for us to get to solutions without having to deal with the political religions
I think one of them is just taking the 25 percent and be like you're religious about this
we can't really talk I prefer to talk to the
50 percent that aren't voting that are in the middle that just don't know what to do with this whole
Situation and then the people that are already sold the vast majority of it, yeah
that is something I talk about which is you actually don't need to convince the outliers and the
extremists in order to win elections because we have 50% voter turnout in this country and
president Trump conceivably could win reelection based on a combination of low voter turnout and our electoral vote system
With an approval in there in the 20s right in the high 20s
You can actually still win a presidential election because people don't vote if the shoutout to George W. Bush, yeah
If the voter turnout went even just from roughly 50 to even something like 62 percent you completely
Marginalize the ability of those extremists who have these related and the religions go beyond the sort of political religion
I think is an interesting term because you see those dogmatic beliefs around
constitutionalism and constitutional originalism the idea of the Constitution
effectively as a
Sacred text similar to the Bible or the Koran or whatever else you see it with this what I call strict father morality
strict father morality is the dogmatic idea that I claim to want to reduce abortion if I am a right winger and
Then someone comes to me and says we know how to do it
Comprehensive sex education and ready access to contraceptives. I'm against that if I'm a right-wing conservative because you are not actually
Behaving in the correct way if you have unprotected. I'm sorry protected sex
non-procreative sex you deserve the
consequences almost like a strict father saying if you do it you should get pregnant and you should be forced to carry the baby to
A full term and give birth to it that is a dogmatic idea fundamentally
It's not a pragmatic idea where we actually know what works to reduce the number of abortions right and I think it applies even beyond
climate change
There's a lot of these pseudo religious
Dogmatic ideas the other one is the free market right that exists on the right this this sort of religious approach to the free market
We uh, I don't actually think that just because we agree to the consensus
Doesn't guarantee what the policy should be and I think that that scares some people on the right?
Certainly the reduction in fossil fuel use is sort of an obvious one
But I think that there's just a lot of people on the right who are scared to admit
That they are aware of the consensus, or just agree with the consensus because they believe that it definitely means
I don't know no more SUVs or whatever
It is but there's still a debate to be had over. What the policy should be although
I think as you pointed out the direction that the policy should go is pretty obvious at this point
It is and I actually I I don't even agree
Necessarily the people on the right are against reducing fossil fuels not because of all yeah because when you actually talk to people
I mean there are plenty of
conservative
Reasons why you should switch to renewable energy absolutely, you know there's people that are for wind in fact um
I'm researching electric cars right now
And one of the people that is rumored to have saved the tax credits is Senator Chuck Grassley of Iowa, yeah
And you can't get more Republican than him
But he's into wind energy and the economics of it makes sense sure so I don't think it's necessarily and just out in the world
There are plenty of people that I know that are Republicans
But are driving electric cars that do care about this that know the science, but that's that's one of the problems
I have with just like dividing people in the left and right because my own father
He's me so annoying that I talk about him, but my own dad was a Republican on when I was growing up
He counts himself as a libertarian now. He drives an electric car. He is singing the praises of it. He volunteered at an
Aquarium for years you know he's really into environmentalism people just don't really fit
Very well into these boxes and when it comes to fossil fuels what I'm witnessing is that our Congress
Which makes the laws is far more extreme yeah, then most of the country on most issues
That's true
And that else has a lot to do with the broader issues of how politics are financed and a lot of other stuff
Yeah, totally the video you just watched was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david pakman show you can make a pledge of as little as $1 per month and
Every dollar helps to support the work that we're doing
Particularly in light of the YouTube ad boycott, which has been really bad